also you don't really need a kitchen
with an air fryer you could kind of stay
in a hotel and use an air fryer you have
to be a little sneaky because it can get
kind of smoky so it's better to get a
hotel where you can cook outside of the
room with a little patio Hotel patio air
fryer suitcase full of meat girls got to
do what a girl's got to do to not have
arthritis
this episode is brought to you by better
fed beef where I get my meat given I
only eat meat and have only eaten beef
or lamb or bison for the last five years
I should be one of the most
knowledgeable sources of what beef to
eat in the world what percentage of the
world has eaten more beef than me just
my dad anyway I get my beef from
butterfed better fed beef is a direct to
Consumer beef company producing A
specialized product called certified
Anya beef Anya beef is like wagyu but
they're nice to the animals super tender
meat I have a massive discount code for
you guys which is good for this episode
because we're doing everything carnivore
but you can get 25 off your order which
which is huge for a meat company when
you go to betterfedbeef.com and use code
MP betterfedbeef.com code MP for 25 off
that's a massive amount saved I'm really
not sure how they're making any money
look at this bad boy this is what you
get look at this you could kill somebody
with this thing anyway I usually get
tomahawks ribs their bone marrow so good
strip lines are good rib eyes are good
they also have things like oxtail and
liver check them out betterfedbeef.com
code MP for 25 off your order
hey there I'm Michaela Peterson welcome
to my channel you guys may have noticed
that I look slightly different it's
because I fixed the focal length on my
cameras technically my husband did and
now I look less like a fish
this is what I actually look like anyway
I'm coming up on Five Years on the lion
diet can you believe that five years of
only eating beef lamb bison salt and
water with the occasional vodka slash
bourbon I'll get into that later as many
of you guys know I came across this diet
out of desperation when I had come off
of psychiatric medications trying to get
my depression under control and my
juvenile idiopathic arthritis that left
me with a hip and ankle replacement at
17 under control because the medical
system was not doing it for me so I
stopped taking all my medication after I
went on the paleo diet when I was 23
very restrictive paleo diet no not
Starry eggs very limited fruit mostly
meat and greens that got rid of all my
symptoms until I came off of psychiatric
medications way too quickly I cold
turkey stopped taking antidepressants
after being medicated from the age of 12
to 23. that was horrific I didn't even
know I was an antidepressant withdrawal
for for a number of years until my dad
experienced the same thing and that's
what led me to the lion diet and I've
been on the lion diet since December
2017 to keep my autoimmune disorder
under control in remission I do not take
any medication and I have no arthritic
symptoms and to keep my psychiatric
conditions in remission because I was
extremely extremely extremely depressed
I had OCD symptoms was diagnosed with
bipolar and I was on a lot of different
medications and I was absolutely
miserable and I'm medication free I'm no
longer an antidepressant withdrawal and
I attribute almost all of My Success to
the lion diet so if people are
interested in it I have a ton of free
information up at liondiet.com I have
recipes you can kind of look into my
blog to see how I got to where I am now
I have an FAQ a very extensive FAQ on
there to help people start the diet I
also have a couple of Facebook groups
don't eat that for kind of elimination
diets health-minded people and the lion
diet for people who are specific
typically on this diet who need a group
of people who aren't going to judge them
while they're doing all beef all lamb
all bison which can elicit some strange
stares and remarks anyway I'm going to
do a q a because I thought why not it's
been five years does the quality of meat
affect your body I.E does it need to be
grass-fed slash organic I do not eat
grass-fed meat very often I don't really
like how it tastes compared to not
grass-fed meat what I don't eat is aged
meat aged meat gives me digestive
problems if I eat aged meat my stomach
hurts almost 15 or 20 minutes after
eating it I've got a very sensitive
digestion but histamine intolerance is
something that's fairly common on a
carnivorous diet and histamine
intolerance is when you react basically
to aged Mead that's a very simplified
way but that's how I'm going to describe
it so I eat lamb and bison which are
generally lower in histamine and aren't
aged as long and I eat beef from better
fed whom I love that's mostly where I
get at my meat and then white oak
pastures has unaged beef and so does
Billy dough so if you start the
carnivore diet and you're having like
urgency issues or bloating after you eat
meat it could be because your body
doesn't like aged meat so I tell
everyone to eat unaged meat at least at
the beginning so lamb and bison you're
pretty much good at the grocery store
and beef you have to go searching for it
from the companies that I just mentioned
everything electrolytes how to move
fully into lion avoiding electrolyte
imbalance slash cramps so when I started
the diet I just went to beef and salt
and water and I didn't know anything
about electrolytes I was trying to
eliminate any variable that could be
causing autoimmunity and so I
suffered fairly badly from electrolyte
imbalances around month five I started
waking up at night because my calf was
cramping and calf cramps they hurt a lot
and I was too worried about introducing
anything because of these massive
autoimmune reactions I would have to
food or to even pills or medication just
anything that I just dealt with it
almost a year into the lion diet I
realized that sodium potassium magnesium
levels especially at the beginning of
the diet are super important I found I
needed a lot of sodium about a third
potassium and less magnesium than that
some people need more potassium you kind
of have to play around with it I would
say just add salt at the beginning a lot
of salt to your diet and then if the
cramps come start playing around by
adding in potassium and adding in
magnesium and unfortunately it's pretty
different per person I tried like a
third potassium that's kind of what
worked for me so you can try that but
even without electrolytes the muscle
cramps and electrolyte imbalances do go
away you don't need these electrolytes
forever but at the beginning of the diet
it really really does help do you take
any supplements or eat organs so one of
the things that really pisses me off
about the carnivore Community is you
have charlatans in here that are
scamming people and I mean any diet
sphere you end up with charlatans
scamming people but I feel like if I've
only been eating beef and lamb and bison
in salt and water for five years then I
can pretty safely say that you don't
really need organs I don't need organs I
don't take organ supplements I think if
you have an aversion to eating organs
like if you eat liver and you're like
then you shouldn't be just putting it in
a pill and forcing it down so I don't
think you need organs there I said it do
you ever crave sweets like fruit mango
pineapples and berries no no I don't
really get Cravings anymore I have
managed to reintroduce wild fish I don't
eat wild fish very often because I seem
to just be hungry after I eat it but
it's nice to be able to go out to a
restaurant and Order Sashimi I can eat a
little bit of honey so that's exciting
have I managed to introduce anything
else like fruit absolutely not I still
get autoimmune symptoms if I introduce
fruit I get autoimmune symptoms if I eat
chicken pork is even worse I cannot
tolerate pork at all I have a worse
reaction to Pork than I do to some fruit
like I'd rather be eating apples than
eating pork how severe are your symptoms
if you eat only a little outside of your
all meat diet it's totally dependent on
the food if I had something containing
gluten very severe if I have something
containing soy like I was on tour with
Dad earlier this year and we went out
for lamb and they cook the Lamb with
olive oil but the olive oil was like 70
soybean oil tons of restaurants Cheap
out and they cut their olive oil with 70
soybean oil it's disgusting and they
call it olive oil you're still allowed
to call it olive oil be careful of your
olive oils guy anyway I had some of the
lamb and I was like okay this tastes a
little weird because you can taste
everything if all you eat is meat for
five years you can like if there's a
pepper flake on my lamb like that's
pepper I don't eat spice I know what
spice tastes like anyway I had a pretty
bad reaction to just a couple of
Lollipop pieces of lamb that had soybean
oil on them but I'm almost deathly
allergic to Soy so that's not that
surprising um I was sick for about a
week I was I cried the next day I felt
horrible I had this overwhelming sense
of Doom and it makes me weepy and my
joints hurt and my skin broke out and it
lasted for about a week now last week I
tried to reintroduce these sausages that
are like fresh beef fat salt sausages
they were so good but about five days
into eating them I started not to feel
so good and I realized they were smoked
so I can't do smoked meat at all
um
yeah I don't know how to explain these
things guys I don't know but I can't do
smoked meat so then my skin broke out a
little bit I'm feeling better that only
lasted about 36 or 48 hours so it was
only like two days so my reactions
seemed to last from two days to a week a
week if they're severe and about two
days for for normal ones that's really
not that bad that's not catastrophic
when I first started the diet when I
went off of psych meds and I was in
Psych Med withdrawal I had horrifying
reactions that would last for an entire
month and they would get worse for 10
days after I stopped eating the food
that I was eating I couldn't believe it
I kept track of my symptoms in a book
because I thought I was crazy it'd just
get worse and worse and worse and I
attribute that now that I know to psych
Med withdrawal I thought that I just had
hypersensitivity to carbs because of my
autoimmunity but it was definitely
combined with psych Med withdrawal and
there are stories all over the Internet
about people experiencing psych Med
withdrawal symptoms that I had which was
like hallucinations feeling of falling
overwhelming sense of Doom I couldn't
see colors very well I couldn't sleep it
was horrible I don't even want to get
into psych meds that's a whole other
video but um now my reactions are quite
they're they're not pleasant the 36
hours even after having the smoked
sausages was not pleasant at all I think
I cried once and I'm not a crier I'm not
a crier I think I cried once but then it
went away in 48 hours that's not so bad
it's not as scary as a month ooh okay
can you do a what I eat in a day okay
what do I eat in a day so this morning I
had cold ribs from last night and I'm
gonna have crunchy things this evening
and crunchy things this is a recipe I
came up with you get pretty creative I
guess if you've only been eating meat
for a number of years I came up with
this recipe you can take any kind of
beef or lamb any kind of meat as long as
it's not ground meat so any cut of meat
that isn't ground meat and pressure cook
it until you can shred it into bits and
then pour all those shredded bits
without the water obviously into an air
fryer add Tallow which is beef fat so
add some sort of fat and then air fry it
with salt and you get shredded crunchy
things that are just God's greatest gift
and if you haven't had them you might
scoff at it but you would be wrong and
you should try them those kind of
recipes are available for free online
diet.com I would just only eat crunchy
things for my entire life
yeah I also sometimes eat jerky so I'd
say the average day is either a steak
around noon and another steak at around
5 PM or leftover ribs and crunchy things
a year ago my average day looked like
lamb sausage and that's just lemon salt
a lamb sausage in the morning and then I
just ate jerky for the rest of the day
so just a lamb sausage jerky diet I love
jerky people are like you just eat just
beef for breakfast like either no
breakfast or yes or a lamb dinner beef
or lamb lunch beef or lamb sometimes
bison is thrown in there sometimes I get
wild neat crunchy things but it's all
beef or lamb or salt Jordan Peterson my
dad his average day is like steak strip
loin steak strip loin steak strip loin
steak he's a lot too he probably eats
three and a half or four pounds of meat
a day he's a beast so just steaks but I
definitely recommend eating crunchy bits
crunchy things
crunchy thinks is probably a better name
and crunchy things is it possible for
someone who has a normal income to do
this diet meat is expensive is it not
and what about travel okay multi-part
question so it's totally possible to do
this on a very low budget it can be way
cheaper than eating the standard
American diet what you want to do is you
want to go to a butcher or go to your
meat department and just buy the cheap
cuts it doesn't matter what they are buy
the cheap Cuts you could survive off of
tongue if you needed to that's dirt
cheap and if you go to my handy website
liondiet.com there is a recipe for
crunchy things and you can literally
make the most garbage cuts into
delicious crispy things by adding fat so
you can buy fat from a butcher fat is
really cheap they commonly cut fat off
of cuts and throw it away so make
friends with a butcher buy fat buy the
cheap Cuts you can do a heart too you
can do organs I know I just talked down
to organs but like heart is it's a it's
a muscle and tongue is a muscle so
that's still muscle meat basically get
the cheap Cuts add fat get a pressure
cooker and an air fryer and you're set
okay and the pressure cooker and air
fryer are an upfront expense at the
beginning of the diet they will save you
so much time and they'll make your food
so good it's really worth investing into
them but you don't have to have a bunch
of money to do this diet it can be very
cheap and it makes you healthier you
should do it especially if you're sick
travel okay because I have histamine
intolerance and I can't eat aged meat
travel's a bit tricky because going out
to restaurants and eating steak isn't an
option because steak is always aged at
restaurants so I can either go out and
eat lamb that's insanely expensive now
generally speaking I literally take an
air fryer ninja XXL sponsor me put it in
a suitcase put it under the plane and
air Fry at the Airbnb that's usually
what I do it's not super glamorous I've
also been known with my husband to just
pack a bunch of frozen meat in a
suitcase and bring it with me with my
air fryer you're like what that's not
fun yeah but you know what's less fun
having an autoimmune disorder and being
crazy that it's way less fun plus it's
kind of hilarious to pack a suitcase
full of meat with an air fryer and then
bring it to an Airbnb you can also do
long-term hotels so if you're to stay
somewhere for a week then there are
hotels that have kitchens in them also
you don't really need a kitchen with an
air fryer you could kind of stay in a
hotel and use an air fryer you have to
be a little sneaky because it can get
kind of smoky so it's better to get a
hotel where you can cook outside of the
room with a little patio Hotel patio air
fryer suitcase full of meat girls got to
do what a girl's got to do to not have
arthritis this episode is brought to you
by schwank grills appropriately chosen
ads for a carnivore episode don't you
think twin girls are the secret behind
high-end Steakhouse style steaks these
girls use patented infrared technology
to reach temperatures up to 1500 degrees
allowing you to cook the perfectly
seared steak to put this in perspective
most grills only reach around 600
Degrees so if you're struggling to cook
a good steak that might be part of the
problem the high temperature of the
Swank Grill makes a massive difference
to The Taste and tenderness of the steak
and the crunchy outside which which is
the best part I just really want to eat
the crunch on steaks I can personally
say this Grill does a fantastic job with
both crunchiness and tenderness and I've
tried a ton of different grills like
most girls out there tried everything
you get bored only eating meat so you
try everything this month is my five
year lion diet anniversary and to
celebrate twin girls created an
exclusive offer just for you guys right
now schwank grills are giving the
biggest discount they've ever done with
255 off when you use code mp255 at
checkout I haven't seen a deal that good
from Swank girls so if you've been
considering buying one of these grills
or getting someone a grill for Christmas
now is probably a good time 255 dollars
off is a good deal you can get that with
code
mp255 at schwinkgrills.com can you take
supplements or do they activate your AI
disease I kind of like that activate
your AI disease can I take supplements
no so I can take unflavored electrolytes
which is why why I'm making a version
for people that's just sodium potassium
magnesium and nothing else and if I'm
fasting or even intermittent fasting
that makes me feel better there's one
other thing I can take barely I've tried
like I got coveted a couple of times so
this diet wasn't like now I never get
sick I have a toddler she gets me sick
all the time so I don't get like deathly
ill or anything and covid was fine it
was covid but I did get it three times I
traveled around a lot though um no
anyway I was getting I was in Tennessee
last year okay so we moved to Tennessee
and I've got terrible tree allergies and
the diets helped my environmental
allergies but it has not gotten rid of
my environmental allergies for sure I am
so allergic to everything it's crazy and
I used to be so allergic to everything
that I was dying now I'm just so
allergic to everything but in Tennessee
I was getting sick and I was getting
bronchitis repeatedly and I was like
what is happening I feel like I'm a kid
again because that used to happen all
the time when I was a kid my daughter
was getting bronchitis all the time and
it was because tree allergies in
Tennessee were so severe it brought back
my asthma so so I tried to take zinc out
of like desperations like maybe zinc
will stop me from getting sick this is
before I knew it was tree allergies
exacerbating the asthma giving me
bronchitis whenever I got a cold even
honey I can't sleep if I take that at
night I can't take zinc I can't really
take Vitamin C at night the only things
I can kind of take I can take a little
bit of vitamin C just for like the sour
flavor just to get some flavor that
seems to be fine I just don't take it at
night and then I take this when I drink
you're like oh no she drinks how could
she drink so I don't drink very often I
used to drink way more when I was sick I
drank so much I don't drink very often
because the hangovers are just brutal
when you don't have any carbs and I get
tired when I drink now it used to
energize me when I was sick and now I
just get tired so I don't drink very
often but when I do drink I drink vodka
I like Tito's or Bourbon and those are
the only two hard alcohols that I'm
aware of where they don't add extra
ingredients after distilling so gin they
add Botanicals after distilling Scotch a
lot of the time they add caramel
coloring they don't in Bourbon it's just
distilled vodka it's just distilled
unless you're in Russia and then they
add sugar and Botanicals like gin
uh Silver Tequila also no ingredients
added after distillation so those three
alcohols Silver Tequila Bourbon and
vodka that isn't Russian they don't give
me any autoimmune symptoms they just
give me a severe hangover and for those
hangovers I take a supplement called
dihydramy-racetin which I'm also
producing because I've been taking it
for like 10 years when I drink way
before I started dieting which is why I
know it works I'll get into it a little
bit they did this it's because it's it's
I think it's funny when I was 20 I was
dying from a hangover and from being
unbelievably ill and I was like how can
it be 20 what I guess 12. how can we not
have a hangover cure it's 2012. and so I
started researching and I found this
herb called dihydramyracetan and I
looked at the study and it was a study
done on rats so what they did to these
poor rats is they just pumped them full
of alcohol so they had rats that were
pumped full of alcohol and then the rats
that were pumped full of alcohol and
dihydromy-racetin and they ran tests on
them so one of the tests was you drop
them in water and you see which which
one just gives up faster so the rat that
had alcohol and dihydromyorcetin swam
longer significantly longer than the rat
that was just drunk they did another
test where you just put the rats on
their back
and see which one flips over faster and
the rot with dihydramycin flipped over
faster and then the third test was they
ran rats through a maze so hung over
rats will just kind of like shiver in a
corner instead of going to get the
cheese or whatever the treat is in the
Maze and rats given
dihydramy-racetin so rather than being
hungover they had they were hungover
with dihydramine ricotine they weren't
as shivery and scared and they went to
get the treat faster so I read that
study and I was like well that sounds
like me when I'm hungover shivering in a
corner I started trying to buy this
dihydroma rice tin which was very
difficult to find and then I spent a
couple years figuring out what dose to
take anyway I've made it into a
supplement called after party which is
launching soon so I do take that but I
only take it when I'm drinking it helps
break down acetaldehyde which is the
toxic byproduct of alcohol and it works
weekly on Gaba so part of what alcohol
does is it desensitizes your Gaba
receptors that's part of what it does
right floods your brain with some Gaba
which makes you feel good good and then
the next day you're kind of anxious
because your receptors are a little
desensitized it works weekly on Gaba so
it works in two ways helps you detoxify
by breaking down acetaldehyde and it
works weekly on Gaba if you take it at a
high enough dose a lot of the
supplements on the market are low dose
and they just don't work anyway that's
coming out soon so I do take that
supplement but that has nothing to do
with my autoimmune disorder that's just
because occasionally I drank and
drinking is bad for you so you probably
shouldn't do it which means you don't
need the supplement the only supplement
I take that's actually for the diet is
electrolytes and I don't take them very
often anymore but I should have taken
them more at the beginning of the diet
there that was a long and drawn out
answer have your periods improved in any
way on the lion diet were they bad
before so I always had like eight days
about eight day periods
um now it's hard to say because I was
also taking birth control
for honestly from like 14 to 23 when I
stopped taking my medications so
I don't even know what a regular period
would look like I know that before I
went on birth control I had pretty bad
cramping I have absolutely no cramping
now
um so I would attribute that to diet but
it's also hard to say because I didn't
actually stop taking birth control until
I started going on Paleo and things and
even paleo really improved my cycle but
um My Cycles super normal and about six
days long and absolutely no cramping do
you ever go off the line diet so no
never never ever ever and I never cheat
because nothing tastes as good as being
healthy feels and the repercussions for
cheating for me are so severe and so
quick that it's just not worth it like
would you eat peanuts if you really like
peanuts if you had a peanut allergy what
if you really liked peanut butter it's
like asking that kind of questions like
well what if you really like fruit yeah
but I get arthritis and my skin breaks
out and then I cry all the time no fruit
tastes that good what I am going to try
right away I've had a number of theories
about this diet over the years you can
check the blog but I like went down the
rabbit hole to everything especially
before I came to diet I I was looking at
everything and right now my theory is
that I have got extremely severe
environmental allergies and I'm getting
cross reactivity in plant food and I
think it kind of makes sense with pork
too because I'm pretty sure and we just
make sure that this is right
yeah crazy okay okay so this actually
this actually seems like a good theory
and I've um I know the owner of a
pharmaceutical company who's good at
this kind of stuff and he said it makes
sense so I think from being born through
a C-section and being put on antibiotics
under the age of six months as a kid I
think that just spiked my immune system
to react to absolutely everything and
I'm hoping and thinking that my
environmental allergies are so severe
I'm reacting to plant food and this
lines up with my serious sensitivity to
Pork which is like why why would I have
a reaction to Pork all I eat is like
beef and lamb and bison why does pork
give me arthritis if you have a cat
allergy you can have a cross reactivity
to Pork I'm so allergic to cats it makes
me hate cats they go into someone's
house and I'm just like oh and they
smell weird and I'm sure if I wasn't
allergic to them I wouldn't feel that
way maybe but um I think my
environmental allergies are so severe
I'm getting cross reactivity to plant
proteins pork proteins and that's
causing just systemic inflammation and
then there's this hypersensitivity
reaction where you can have if you have
leaky gut which can be caused especially
if you're gluten intolerant your gut is
very thin you can have permeability
issues where food proteins leak into
your bloodstream and then your body
starts attacking these food proteins
which they treat like bacteria or virus
they're not supposed to be in your blood
you can say this is a little like food
protein floating around your blood your
body can attach little antibodies all
over it and then those can start to
build up in tissues if your body can't
get rid of them fast enough if you keep
ingesting these Foods so I think that's
kind of what happened to me combined
with this environmental allergy Theory
so say my theory is correct say I'm so
allergic to the environment which is
true I'm so allergic to like grass mold
tree cockroaches they test you for that
dust mites horses cats dogs anything
with fur other than rabbits not entirely
sure why just just everything which I
think is also why I'm allergic to smoke
I'm so allergic to smoke if I go to a
campfire and then I sleep with the smoke
in my hair I wake up not being able to
breathe the next morning I'm like EpiPen
allergic to the world it's nuts anyway
how do you desensitize yourself from
environmental allergies if you're
allergic to everything well I've come
across a couple of companies that do
sublingual so they take a little bit of
the allergen so say like cat dander tiny
tiny little bit of cat dander and they
put it in glycerin and I don't think I'm
allergic to glycerin and then you put it
under your tongue you put like a drop in
once a day and over a period of one to
two years theoretically this helps or
eliminates 80 percent of people's
environmental allergies everybody should
know about this stuff they used to do
allergy desensitization in shots and you
have to go into the doctor's office
multiple times a week and get shots and
now they have sublingual drops and
they've shown this to help people with
say peanut allergies because kids will
like die from these things they'll hop
on a plane they'll have a peanut allergy
reaction and they'll die this has
happened and they're starting to do
these this sublingual immunotherapy for
kids who have severe food allergies and
I have you know severe soy allergies and
everything else anyway that's my theory
so I'm going to be trying
desensitization therapy through
sublingual drops and I will keep you
guys posted because wouldn't that be
crazy if this was environmental
allergies the whole time that were so
severe that eating plants was giving me
environmental allergies environmental
allergies systemically leading to an
autoimmune disorder
tell me about your teeth so I actually
have veneers because my teeth were so
bad when I was like 17 and I'm sure sure
it was from diet I my enamel wasn't very
very damaged um that I got veneers my
gums Never Bleed on this diet though I
used to have bleeding gums all the time
and they stopped on this diet but I
can't say that like my beautiful white
teeth are from this diet because I just
paid for them were you pregnant or
nursing on this diet yes I had a
miserable pregnancy I was horribly
depressed the entire time I don't know
if it was from the hormones or the
antidepressant withdrawal or both I went
on the diet five months into nursing
when Scarlet was still nursing full-time
she hadn't introduced any foods and I
switched over into the diet I got more
milk Scarlet's cradle cap went away
obviously I got better that improved
things so yes and there are people Kelly
Hogan she has hordes of children and
she's on a carnivore diet she's not on
the lion diet exactly she eats a little
bit more than that but she's on a
carnivore diet and has lots of kids so
there are people out there that do this
Charlene Anderson she used an all-beef
diet for Lyme disease she has multiple
children that are also on the diet so
yes if you have postpartum depression I
know a couple of people on the diet that
it's helped postpartum depression a lot
so I'd say give it a shot no use living
depressed living there's nothing worse
than that
you know I know when you're depressed
you think oh how could I go on a diet
the only pleasure I have is from food
just do the diet don't live depressed
especially if you've lived depressed for
like a decade or that's been your life
forever that's so sad part of the reason
I talk about this stupid diet
is because it's completely saved my life
it saved my Dad's life it saved my mom's
life my mom had really bad arthritis and
a whole bunch of other issues she thinks
she would be dead without the diet she
almost died anyway uh my dad would be
dead 100 without the diet he needed it
for psych Med withdrawal and
autoimmunity and it's just there's
nothing nothing as bad as mental health
problems and I think a lot of them are
exacerbated by the psych meds that
people are taking they're so dangerous
and people don't understand withdrawal
or how dangerous they are I've seen this
diet help tons of people and so if
you're thinking about doing it and
you're depressed do it for six weeks
it's not that long do it for six weeks
and then decide if you want to keep
doing it at the six week part it's not
that long okay it's a lot less Long than
spending the rest of your life depressed
do you miss eating socially so yes but
whenever I went out to eat I was always
and I was taking antidepressants and
this can be a side effect of
antidepressants but I was always
Starving in ravenous in kind of a hangry
way I'd eat and I'd still be hungry it
wasn't that much fun I didn't eat you
know I wasn't one of those people that
was like I'll have a bite of that cake
and then I'll be done I'd have a bite of
that cake and I'd want to eat the whole
cake I'd have a bowl of pasta and I'd
I'd be so full from eating this pasta I
had celiac disease too so that didn't
help but I'd be so full for meeting this
pasta and so hungry I'd be on like the
verge of tears eating out was my thing
like I ate out constantly Sushi was my
favorite food I'm so allergic to Soy so
I find that kind of funny because I put
soy on everything I was at foodie I hate
that term but I was a foodie and so do I
miss it I missed it terribly missed it
for the first couple years when I was in
coming off of medications and still very
sensitive and having month-long
reactions and ridiculed by my friends
but it wasn't worth the autoimmune
disorder or the mood disorder so I
didn't really have a choice so now do I
miss it now I'm unfortunate enough that
I can go out and eat at steakhouses if I
want to go out but honestly I work all
the time and don't really go out to eat
anymore it's not a big part of my life
anymore
cookbook cookbook is coming I just don't
want my first book to be a cookbook
that's a very fast answer that question
I have a memoir I want to put that out
first for now all the recipes are for
free online diet.com
why'd I call it the lion diet I called
it the lion diet because it's not a cool
diet and you're a total dweeb when
you're on it like you feel like a dweeb
you're
socially weird and it's really
frustrating and you lose all your
favorite foods and you're probably sick
to begin with and I wanted this diet to
have some sort of strong name and be
cooler tried to make it cooler because
being sick sucks and
the all beef diet just sounded so bad so
I guess people might say the lion died
as cringy but I know that you need a
certain amount of
strength in order to combat chronic
disease and you need that same kind of
drive to do it without the medical
system with diet because that is so
Cutting Edge and so new that people
won't believe you and you need to be
strong and I thought the lion diet kind
of embodied that and lions only eat meat
people are like well Lions don't eat
salt haha are you eating raw meat like a
lion not saying I'm a lion you nerds
just called it the lion diet now does
that end my lion diet q a can I squish
one more in here you have all your
problems because you have chronic lyme
disease what's you think what you think
I think I was diagnosed with chronic
lyme disease so that could be true
doesn't change anything though okay then
this is I could take a stab at this one
why is it that eating the lion diet
cures what you were struggling with so
this is
just a guess because everything about
most diets nowadays is just a guess but
I think I had leaky gut so I think my
gut was damaged partially from having
celiac disease and partially from eating
gut damaging foods and food was escaping
into my blood you know like bacteria
into that food and those antibody
antigen complexes were building up in my
tissues and giving me arthritis I think
that's what was giving me autoimmunity
and I know that it's been shown paleo
medicinea in Hungary might be medichina
paleo medicinea paleo medicinea they've
showed that putting people on an all
ruminant meat diet stops gut
permeability issues it will seal your
gut so that's part of it at least is if
you only eat ruminant meat you can heal
gut damage so that's part of it and then
the other part of it I think I'm
actually allergic to plants I'm allergic
to environmental plants I'm allergic to
Grass I'm allergic to grass and trees
and like flowers and weeds and
everything outdoors why wouldn't I be
allergic to plants as well it's not just
from removing processed foods a lot of
people look at the diet and they're like
well if you had just removed processed
foods you'd be fine
and I did do that
do that first because
I removed everything I thought I could
be allergic to nuts eggs dairy all
processed foods grains and went down to
like meat and greens and fruit I did
that to begin with and then I stopped
taking antidepressants and I went off of
all my medications and I got pregnant
and that stopped working okay so then I
went to meet and lettuce I was just
eating meat and lettuce and apple cider
vinegar and olive oil not olive oil cut
with soybean oil just pure olive oil and
that was giving me an autoimmune
disorder it wasn't until I dropped the
literally lettuce apple cider vinegar
olive oil and went to the lion diet that
my arthritis went away and my mood
improved so it's not from cutting
processed foods it's more than that
anyway I have theories about why it's
Works got permeability issues but I hope
that if you're sick you give it a shot
I've tried to put everything I can for
free online diet.com it's been five
years and here I am
without scurvy and yeah I'm gonna go do
a podcast
hope you guys are doing well and if you
need a reason to try the diet do it just
try it for six weeks join my Facebook
group people in there are nice they will
be nice to you they'll help walk you
through it and everything's free I hope
this q a was helpful I'll do another one
at some point I hope everyone's feeling
good